All right, the first thing I
want to cover is the, UM, the
peer group feedback. I want to
remind you. There's only been,
uhm, maybe a dozen or so people
that have given feedback to the
last set of groups that that
presented. You'll notice that 10
points of your presentation
individually is allocated to
participation in both tenants
making relative contributions
and. Um, peer feedback. So those
of you who have presented
already yet having given
feedback, um, have seen, um.
Some of those points taken off
from an individual standpoint
I'll. I've kept the feedback for
the last set of groups open and
we'll till about 5:00 o'clock
this afternoon. So if you
haven't done it, I would
encourage you to do it quickly.
It's only fair to to share your
feedback with teams that have
shared feedback with you.
Also remind you, um with regard
to the final exam. The final
exam is on a Tuesday May 5th
from 12:45 to 2:45 PM. The
content to the exam will be
similar to the mid term in that
there will be a collection of
multiple choice questions that
will also be a few essay
questions. It will be
comprehensive just in the in the
the fact of the way we've
covered the content throughout
the course of the semester.
And so you'll certainly.
Um, have to rely upon the things
that you've learned over the
course is message. There's
nothing that will go back to
that we haven't used in the last
several weeks, and then I want
to remind you also that the top
team on the Kegl Private
leaderboard will be exempt from
the final exam if they so
choose. Uhm, I wanna make it
clear that from the UM, the
fact that it's a let me go
back to the private
leaderboard because the
public leaderboard is what
shared now. The private
leaderboard will be exposed
once all of the once the
contest is complete on Sunday
night at at midnight.
I'll tell you that the
competition is pretty fierce.
And Uhm.
And there is likely.
And I don't know until the till
the till the final curtain is
drawn as it were, but there's
likely some movement on the
private leaderboard from the
public leaderboard. So just
because you find yourself and
5th or 6th place or even in
first place, you may find
yourself in a different place
once the private leaderboard is
exposed, the private leaderboard
takes 60% of the data that
you've scored versus 40%, which
is shown in the public
leaderboard. So probably your
board is meant to be a kind of a
guiding post for how well you're
doing in the in the contest
overall, but you want to
continue to refine your models
and um, and have some.
Continue to try to to.
Improve your value and look
on the leaderboard. I will
point out to you that just
because your models don't
necessarily seem to improve
in sassy and remember you're
only scoring them against a
small subset of data. And as
some teams have discovered,
even when they had really,
really, good, sassy, and uh.
Root mean squared errors, but
uhm, you know in the 10 to 15 to
20,000 which would put them at
the top of the leaderboard, they
found significantly different
outcomes with the test data that
was submitted to the private or
to the rather to the Calculator
board. So I would encourage you
to submit as many models as
possible to the Calculator.
Bored because you never know.
Um, if uh?
If one of those models is
less overtrained than
another, In other words,
it's less fit to just the
training data that you
might actually have
improved on your.
In your cable spot, so
don't come, don't hesitate
to submit often.
All right?
Finally, Uhm, I just want to
talk about the, UM, the final
models. And so this is where
you're headed to. Now you're
going to apply these three
additional models since your
initial set of models.
So based on the snapshot that we
took last time, the number of
models that were submitted, I'll
be looking for three more
models. Uhm, I want to ask you
in Kaggle to um to take your
team to join to merge teams with
the with the other folks that
are on your team. About half of
you have done so. It just makes
it a lot easier for me to keep
up with who is on what team and
what have you as opposed to
individuals. You can do that in
Kaggle just by going to your
team and then um.
There's a. There's a dialogue
there that that asks you to
merge. Maybe I'll share that bit
and you can. You can ask others
who are on your team to merge
then your your models are are
all scored together so that the
Top Model you have is scored as
a as a larger team.
OK. I wanna just talk about the,
uh, the paper a little bit the
the final paper, the final, the
final deliverable for this
project. Those are you are doing
the paper and then those who are
also delivering their
presentation. I want you to
think about this as a complete
journey through all three. Sorry
through all three milestones
we've had so far. But through
the entire course send some
since basically spring break.
When we started this project.
I want you to to think about the
way that we've gone through many
of the homework assignments.
We've talked about a bit of the
understanding the business
understanding so maybe a
sentence or two there want you
to think about the data
understanding. This is the part
that you've already done right
in the first milestone. I want
you to talk about some of the
insights. You saw there and kind
of tie them all together. I've
updated the the document.
Rubric Abit in blackboard. Just
to show the UM.
To give you some more sense
of of how to pull it
together into a single
document. So we're looking
for is is something that
that tells the whole story
throughout the process and
includes the recommendations
at the very end.
Again, my hope is that you can
take your experience, not just
your experience but also your
document, your presentations and
use them as part of your
portfolios. You start looking
for come for internships for
summer employment or employment
going forward there. It's a
great kind of thing to show off
whether you have a website
portfolio, website or you bring
a printed copy with you. It's a
nice thing to have if you've
done a good job on.
Um?
I would suggest to you to
include both the sassy M score
Anna Cagle score for your top
models, so as you think about
it, uhm, the there was a lot of
places in the.
In the last deliverable where
you posted your sassy am scores
or many teams did poster sassy M
scores to kind of call out which
were the best models that they
had. Which is great.
I would just encourage you to
think about also adding the
Kegel score that you got for
those that you can kind of refer
back to them on which one of the
models. It's kind of a running
log for yourself of how close
those two scores were.
Hum.
Many of you also used a lot of.
Uh.
Language, lot of verbosity,
verbosity. Rather sorry in the.
In describing your models,
especially for the model
parameters and all, I think
while that's fine and it still
makes sense, it might be better
and easier for you to just
highlight with bullet points or
tables. The key model
parameters. That way you can if
you need to put those into the
appendix that they're not
cluttering up your document, and
you can focus your document on
on just the key aspects that
require words and don't have
numbers and. And, uh, parameters
associated with them.
I also want to point out that
you can highlight specific
parts of the model without
having to use to paste the
entire model into your into
your document at once. I would
encourage you to take just
different sections, like will
do later and you'll see later
in the the slide show and
you've seen it before where
I've just cut out like the
three or four important.
Things that we want to highlight
or talk about and use those
instead of trying to capture
your entire. Um, your entire
model in one big picture that
can be helpful to see it in one
big picture, but it also.
Be helpful, um the The Fidelity
and detail you can get from just
having a few nodes as part of
your screen shot is great.
And then like I said, I've
updated the assignment document
with just some.
Um, somewhere verbage that you
can understand. Kind of what I
what what I've just laid out
for you, um, there's no
changes to what's required,
just a kind of an approach to
how to think about it.
Any questions on the final
models and we're headed there.
All right, I'm gonna move on.
OK so for today oh good, I
didn't put the agenda slot
in so for today we're
going to talk about, uhm?
A couple of more techniques for
improving your models.
Specifically, we're going to
talk about on sampling. That is,
combining multiple models
together and voting on the
results were going to talk about
two other methods.
Call boosting and bagging,
both of which are uhm, can
be valuable in helping to
improve your models by all
three of which use.
Either samples of the data to to
create multiple models and then
combine the results or take
different model types and
combine the results. We'll see
examples of those as we go
through today, but but those
three areas are places where you
might consider more tools to add
to your tool belt.
This is a reminder on the the
public and private
leaderboard at the current.
Currently, we're currently
$3500 root mean squared error
difference. So really we're
talking about less than.
Right around 2 1/2 to 3%
separate. The first four places.
So there's there's lots of
opportunity for you move up
the leaderboard and um and
also there's already two
teams that have beat the
instructor points and have
gained themselves 505 bonus
points for the project by
doing so, so continue to. I
haven't updated my model. I
won't be updating. My model
anymore. So if you can beat
the score. That's there,
you're in great shape.
All right? Um, our schedule will
talk about where we're headed
here in a minute.
Alright, so we talked about were
still on this uhm mode of
feature engineering. In other
words, creating new features or
improving our models. Bye bye.
By their creating new features
from existing features or
combining models together, we've
talked about using clusters and
will show an example today of
how to use.
Some of the things that we've
learned for a cluster, how we
can use clusters as a new
feature. We've talked about
transformations last week where
we created new transformations,
and some of the groups even did
for their early models where
they created, for instance, the
total square foot of the house,
or they decided that if it had a
pool or a deck or.
Something that in fact it was
considered a premium feature,
and so that was, uhm, a
transformation. We created a new
feature. We talked about
principle components. Which
look for the combination of
features that offer the most
variation or the most
variability in the data set,
and today will talk about
ensemble Ng.
So as I talked about, we've kind
of got 3. Modes on Samling being
a combination of models, trying
to put multiple models together
to achieve better outcomes,
there's a few different
approaches. There's a bagging
approach. Bagging really is
where we would take um,
multiple models. We would do
them in parallel. In other
words, typically what we
would do in bagging is we may
split the model into.
Into some kind of segments or
into some kind of group and we
would. We would take multiple
models, execute them in
parallel, and then vote on the.
Either vote if it's a
classification problem or we use
the mean of predictions almost
like a K nearest neighbors
approach but with models.
Boosting models is an approach
where the models are produced in
series, really, that In other
words the models. The first
model is run or will run our
data through. The first model
will find the most.
Ah.
The most problematic or the the
biggest errors in that model
and will re run it through that
same model again using. Uhm,
what we call the residuals or
the errors to continually try
to make that one model better
by running our errors and
overweighting those errors.
In our, you know, in multiple
passes through the same model.
So In other words, if we find,
let's say we have five
observations and we find that
observations one and two were
really well that observations
one and two made a lot of
sense and really.
They had a very our predictions
where weren't very far off, but
models 3 for observation 3,
four and five from our
validation set were way off.
Then what we would do is we
would go back through and we
would look for Rose in the
validation or in the training
set that matched those that
were so far off on the
validation set and we would
essentially.
Uh, add that row back to our
data set one more time and so
now instead of just 12345 we
have one 2334455 and we continue
to do so. Adding those that are
most problematic back into our
set so that we can improve the
places that have poor
predictions. Fortunately, the
software does a lot of this
stuff for us, so the importance
and I'll show you a picture in a
second. Gonna make this all make
a little more sense and then
finally we have, uhm, we call
stack modeling stack modeling
our models that are are produced
either in series, UM where we
take the outputs of one model
and feed them into the.
Feed them in as.
As new features in later models.
So if we were doing, for
instance a a classification
method, we might.
Run a decision tree.
And Uhm. And decide which
class that the output belonged
in, and we would add that as a
new factor that would then be
sent to a regression algorithm
kind of further down the line.
Again, will show some examples
leaves in just a minute, but
this is another technique we
can use where you kind of put
models in parallel models in
series so that they get
executed one after another and
each one adds to what we know
about the later models.
So.
In terms of bagging, again,
this is the case where we add
more models. So if you can
think about this, let's let's
say we have.
If we ask you what the the
population of the United States
is. In the in the in the bagging
approach what we do is we ask
one person with the population
of the. Of the United States
is and we get a prediction
and then in order to get a
better prediction, what we
would do is we would go ask
more people and so the more
people we just keep adding
more people to the two are.
To our to our query or we had
a crowd basically and and by
having more models and reusing
different different
approaches, typically on the
same model with different
sampling.
In other words, we'd be asking
the same question. What do you
think the the population that I
heard population in the United
States is by getting more and
more people will come get a lot
closer to the actual results? At
least that's the idea where it
is in boosting. This is an
approach where we teach the same
model to learn from its prior
mistakes, and so instead of
adding more models to the mix,
what we do is we typically we
start off with a simple model
like. In this case it's, uh?
I've used that kind of
progression from a baby to a
senior citizen. Hum, we take a a
single model. And use those
mistakes to refeed that model
and to improve that model
multiple times through and so.
You would see for instance. Uhm,
this is often done with decision
trees, and there's a. We have an
example. I'll show you in the UM
in our in sassy am here in a
minute, but basically will take
the results from a particular
model. And then we'll take the
errors, will oversample the
errors and then run them through
and our model continues to get
better and better as it learns
from its mistakes.
We could so far.
OK.
And here's the example
of stacked ensemble.
The this picture came from good.
I'm glad to see some feedback.
That's great. This picture
actually came from.
A paper that that sass put out
that showed how they went about
applying a stacked ensemble, and
this is a very common.
A very common solution,
especially to those um to the
competitions, the datamining
competitions, the public ones on
Kaggle, and dumb ones that are
done pretty often is that models
are created. In this particular
case they sass created multiple
feature sets and they they they
created 64 model single models
all by themselves to try to
compare to each other the green
ones. Are we call gradient
boosted decision trees
will talk about that in a
minute. The pink ones are
neural networks. The UM.
The Orange ones are.
Uh, decision forests, basically,
um, there's some regression.
There's some. Uh, and there's a
few other types of models here.
They took 64 different models
and let them all predict their
results. They then fed those
results. Into um, they combined
them together. They combined a
subset of those together into
what they called their stage one
ensemble. So they took their
best models. From here they
combine them together into a
smaller subset of models and you
can see here. So we're down to
115 models, and so these these
64 models became 15 models.
Pulled together and then those
15 got pulled together into
two models, so two different
combinations. Of these 15
where one and became a stage
two ensemble. Now with the
stage two ensembles. So this
takes all of the learning that
we had in the largest model.
And we've improved it in our
ensemble, and then we've
improved yet again, by ensemble
one more time.
And then they've gone in, fed
back in these 64 single
models, the results of those
single 64 models as 64 more
factors in the prediction. And
they've ensemble that. Yet one
more time with their stage two
ensemble and came up with a
stage three ensemble.
The important aspect here is
that they thought about
combining different types of
models together, so all of these
gradient boosted models here all
had a different set of settings,
so they weren't just taking the
same model and.
Kind of bring it together. What
they're doing is they're trying
to make sure that the data looks
different enough that we kind of
get to look at it from multiple
different angles. They also
could use different feature
sets, so In other words, in some
of these models they did some
variable selection or that maybe
they dropped out the weird to
apply to our date it, so maybe a
couple of these gradient
boosting models dropped out the
neighborhood or dropped out.
Some of those fields that had
lots of nulls in them, so some
of them did. Some of them
didn't. In that way we can see
whether or not those models
helped or not. Um, and then
finally we can apply different
training sets and you'll see an
example of this is that some
just a minute where we can take
the universe of data that we
have the number of however many.
Training up nodes that we have
and we can uhm.
Basically, sample out of that
that that population. So instead
of applying our training,
instead of splitting our our
training data set in just 7030
or 6040, however, you want to
think about it in the training
and validation we can actually
take 25% of that data and then
split it. Um, uh 6030 so that
gives us the opportunity to to
look at just part of the
training set and how we decide
to split. That is is also a
question. Will show a few
examples when we get to the
sassy in parts.
Um, for instance, we might
just take a random 25% use
that same 25% like 25% of
each of the model.
And apply four different uhm
models to 25% of the data and
then have them, um?
Uh, compare their results
together into a into an
improved model.
All right?
And so. When I talk about
sampling, so this is the case
where we take just a portion of
the model and then we pretend
that's all we have, so we have
come. We have kind of a couple
of different ways to think about
sampling. We can use a random
number for sampling, so In other
words we can pick just some
percentage based on a random
number. You've seen one of the
parameters and lots of our, or
rather in the data partition is
a random number seed. The
computer doesn't actually
produce random numbers, it's
very difficult to do. It's just
an equation really that gets
applied. And so that seed if we
apply a seed, then we're
guaranteed to get the same
result every time. Just makes it
more predictable. We don't want
to get a totally different
sample of data every time we go
through. We wouldn't get a. You
know we have wildly different.
Um, results from our models even
running the same model more than
once, so we by using a random
seed we still get random data,
but we get the same random date
every time. So one technique to
to sampling is to just get
random amount manual data, and
this is typically the default,
the stratified approach.
Requires equal amounts from
each target category, so In
other words, if we're going
to stratify our example,
typically the way we stratify
it is based on the.
The category we're trying to
get. So in the case of our
turn data, we're trying to
figure out if a customer was
going to turn or leave our
service over the next month.
We make sure in our stratified
sampling that we got an equal
proportion from the number
that did churn as to the
number that didn't turn an.
This helps them to make sure
that that were not.
Uh. Over fitting to the majority
class. In other words, if most
of our customers didn't turn and
we just did random sampling,
it's possible that we may only
get one or two out of 100 UM in
the random sample that did
churn, and therefore we wouldn't
have very good predictors for
those that turned. We do assume
that everyone didn't turn 98% of
the time, so with the stratified
example, this helps us to make
sure that we're getting.
Um? Enough of both classes
to to actually predict one
or the other.
We can use the clustering
approach to sampling and this is
where we would would get equal
amounts from different groups,
not necessarily the target, but
from different groups. So to say
for instance we developed a
cluster from based on the.
The. Neighborhood that, uh, that
they lived in or um, or if we
look back at our clusters that
we created earlier, we don't
actually know because we're in
unsupervised mode. We don't
necessarily know what may accept
those clusters or why those
clusters are are more valuable
than another, but we could.
We could use that cluster um
identifier which cluster
belonged to come as a.
As a group to draw our sample
from, make sure we got some from
every from every one of those
clusters. Uhm, you recall system
systemic sampling where we take
every N number of samples, In
other words. We can choose, UM,
every third we want, you know,
every every third observation
will go into this into this set,
and then finally, there's a
cross validation approach. The
cross validation approach kind
of works its way through the.
Works its way through the
sample, making sure that each
component is is both part of the
test as well as the validation
set, but it's on multiple times.
I think I have an example of
Cross validation, yes, so cross
validation being one of the more
difficult ones to understand. I
thought I would. I would just
show an example. So this is what
we call K fold cross validation.
So for every iteration through
our validation. We take um, one
cake for lack of a better term
of the data is used for our,
uhm, our test data or validation
set. This particular picture use
the word task data. We think of
it as validation. So let's say
in this particular case there's
if you look on the right there's
four iterations, and so we've
taken the data set and we divide
it into four chunks, and so each
one 4th. Of the data, and so
the first iteration we've
taken the first 4th of the
data, and that's become our
task data, and we've saved the
other three force for training
data the second time through,
we shift, and now the second
4th is our test data, and the
first, 4th, second, 4th, and
3rd, 4th our training data. So
on and so forth.
This is valuable to us because
we can, uhm.
We can ensure that all of the
data that we have. Becomes part
of both the training data set
and the validation data set.
Currently, the way we've been
doing it so far, we've only
taken 1 sample of the data.
We've taken our entire
population and we've just simply
split it into 7030.
In an approach like, um, K
fold will actually make sure
that every single observation
is both part of testing and
part of training.
OK so I have a few pictures in
here. I think I'm going to, um,
just go ahead and share directly
in sass. It will give us a
better sense, but I wanted to
make sure you had some of the
screenshots in here. Uhm, and
some reminders of exactly what
it looks like when we were when
we are applying these things so.
Um quickly, just this is a large
example of bagging insights,
where we've taken examples of
our data set. So in this case,
25 percent, 25 percent, 25
percent, 25%. And we've
partitioned that into
training, validation and
then applied the same tree
to it and then brought the
examples together, will go
through. I think this is
more valuable if we just
look at it and sass.
My boosting perspective. I just
wanted to point out that it is
this is one of the most common
techniques that that when data
competitions you'll see
regularly. If you've read any of
the the Katie Nets sites or
kaggle competitions, most all of
them use either some kind of
either gradient boosted trees,
gradient boosted algorithms, XG
boost or something called
lightdm, lightdm, say.
Um, a Microsoft research
algorithm that is come a
white gradient boosted
um modeling approach.
And so.
We go again, will go through an
example of how to do that in
Sassan, just second. So let's go
to sass. And.
I think it will make more sense.
So.
Alright, so.
Um?
If you can't see the screen, let
me know. Otherwise I'm going to
assume we can. You know we're
going to move on the you'll
recognize that this model is,
you know, from our our our aims
housing data set.
Um, what I wanted to show here,
and one the one component you
haven't seen so far. A control
point is really just a place for
all of the so that I didn't have
to continually. If I wanted to
add something before after these
three different models, I didn't
have to continue to add lines or
remove line, so this is just a
connection point to bring all of
them together. The first thing I
wanted to show you is what we
call an samling. Remember, I
told you that you can.
Some kind of take the results
of multiple models and bring
them together, and So what I've
shown here in this example is
from our control point. After
we split our data, I've run a
decision tree with the default
values in it. I've run decision
tree that uses 3 branches and
goes to a depth of.
Adaptive 8 um splits and um,
applied regression model. Now
each one of these.
Um? I didn't. I guess I didn't
connect the regression model 2.
Around this real quick while
we're talking bad.
OK, So what you'll notice I've
done here is I've taken the
results of each one of these
models separately, and I've
compared them and I've also
combined both two decision trees
together into a model.
And so two decision trees are
applied to the data and then the
results are are pulled together
into a fourth model. And then
I've also shown you that you can
actually combine the results of
two different kinds of models.
And so in this particular case
I'm combining the decision tree
with three branches. Anna depth
of eight with the regression
model into what I called
ensemble multiple, and so we're
going to end up with 123.
45 different models to to look
at in to see which the result,
which is the best and so out of
those. Let's take a look
at our results.
OK, we can see is that we're
actually getting great results
from both the ensemble models.
They're actually performing much
better than the models by
themselves. Notice we have an
average square array.
This is actually an average
prayer. We don't because of
the way trees work. That's
the way they call it out.
We don't actually have a.
Oh yeah, we do. We have a
root average squared error.
You'll notice that in
our ensemble model, let
me get our validation.
Our average square.
Interesting.
So they shun.
Route average squared error.
OK.
So what we're seeing here is.
Um.
A rude average squared error for
the ensemble 2 model is about
$200 better than our ensemble
model, and both of those are
$2000 better than the decision
tree or the regression by
itself. So we've taken 2 models
that weren't great, and we've
created a model using 22.
A weaker models an
into a really solid.
A really solid model that that
combines both them together.
Now, one of the things that, UM.
We'll come back to this, but I
want to point out that as we
look at these models annual
notice, these are the models
themselves. The here's our
decision tree with three
branches. Notice that our it
wasn't. It didn't do very good
for whatever reason around the
200 to $300,000 range, but it
did really well. Kind of, UM,
past $300,000 and up, and so
combining that with a model
that. Did great up to about
three $300,000 and then we kind
of went off.
The rails.
Putting those two models
together, you can imagine might
give us better result because
the one that didn't do so well
in the middle actually did do
really well in the middle of the
mother model, and this one did
really well. Kind of at the top
end and this one didn't do so
well, and so using the
combination of those models we
might actually get a better
model. And that's actually what
we saw here. This is our
ensemble, where it's $2000
better than the.
Um, then the default tree and
$4000 better than the tree with
come with three branches, and
then we can Scroll down and see
our regression model as well.
And This is why we can see that
our best model really was the
combination of the regression
notice from about 2:50 to
400,000 or so. Our regression
didn't do so well. It did really
well, kind of.
Up to about 250,000, it really
did pretty well and this is
almost in exact.
Uh, this is where this model did
really well, and so we're kind
of replacing the the poor part
of our regression model.
With the the best
part of our uhm.
Our our decision tree with three
branches and a depth of eight,
and that's exactly what we can
see in the results here is that
we've got a root average squared
error of 4340, three 1192. Now
you might say that's not great
relative to the models you
built, and that's likely so
these are just default
regression models and all you
may find that combining 234.
Or even five of your
existing best models.
Result, you know, kind of take
out even more of that. Um, even
more of the error here. So
that's one approach that we can
use. Uhm, I also want to point
out that I sent out last week a.
Unfortunately, after y'all did
your first pass, I sent out a
snippet that you could build a.
Um?
Kind of a.
Uh, a sass code snippet that
would allow you to.
Actually, take care of not
having to. Um?
Continually go in and and change
the fields that you didn't want
in your output file and change
the name of the output file.
Uhm, and so if you'll take a
look I just dropped day.
I think it was under the utility
node. I just dropped a uhm.
Code note on there and I pasted
in the UM, this is in the the
document I posted. The cable
improved improved workflow. You
notice in this particular case I
used, you'll need to change the
directory to your directory, of
course and then and then. This
will output. This will drop all
of the fields except for the
order and the prediction, and
then it will rename the
prediction. Come to you sale
price and so the result of um
running that means that I don't
have to run a save note anymore
and you can see here.
The result is something like
this. It uses aims underscore
and then a timestamp and the the
output of the file is exactly
what needs to be submitted to
Kaggle. So no in between steps
anymore if you apply that.
Um, a node like that to your to
your design. So just a kind of
a handy hint that might save
you a little bit of effort.
All right? Ensemble.
Let's look at a bagging
approach. I showed you in
the initial.
A video or initial powerpoints
kind of a bagging approach will.
Here it is in detail again I've
used the control point just as a
kind of a collection point for
all the things that came before.
Each one of these I've created
two models. I've created one
on the left, which is a bag
set of trees. So each one of
these I've taken a sample.
I've used the sample.
From our Only sample menu have
used the sample node over here
and um, what you'll notice is
I've looked for a random sample
of 25% of the data. Now you may
decide to choose a random sample
of 10% of the data and put ten
of these trees on your model and
then bring them back together.
What this does and you got to
make sure that this is where I
told you gotta change the random
seed. If you don't change the
random seed, you're gonna end up
with the same 25% to each one of
these, and so each one of these
you'll notice has a different
random seed 123 and.
5 whatever you can make those
numbers whatever you'd like is
just a starting point for the
computer to start creating
random seeds. I've so I've
sampled our entire data set down
to just 25%, and then I've
partitioned it into 7030.
You'll notice that I'd use the
high performance data mining
tools. No reason other than
because I'm doing them in
parallel or because I'm doing so
many of them. I just wanted it
to run faster and so these nodes
tend to run faster because they
are spread across multiple
machines in the background.
Um and they all run at the same
time, and then each of my
trees. In this particular case,
these trees are exactly the
same, so I didn't do anything
to change these trees. They're
all exactly the same there,
just operating on different
parts of the data. So in this
case I get 25% of the data. In
this case I get a different 25%
of the data again here and
again here, and like I said,
you could go ahead and and.
You don't do five 610 whatever
you like in terms of that, and
then what I've done is I've
brought them all back together
so each of these four models
which have operated on just 25%
of the tree, allowed them to
ensemble back together into a
single model. And I've done a
similar thing over on the right
hand side here, but I've used
regression instead of trees, and
all of these regression models
are again exactly the same.
You'll notice they use the.
The exact same linear regression
approach with stepwise
selection, all all of them do
the exact same thing.
Um? The the difference that I
wanted to that I wanted to
introduce in this model for
myself was to was the sample of
data or the different data that
came in and so that was the
difference. I could just as
easily have operated on each of
these samples and then applied
multiple techniques to them as
well and will see in this
particular case I don't remember
how well this one did, but.
This May.
Who's the other one? About
40,000 or so?
And so in this case, um, our
validation root average
squared air, we're down to
about 20,000 um.
Hum.
To about $20,000 for root root
mean squared error are messy, so
that's not bad at all actually.
Uhm, I think that's even better
than what we had in the previous
models, I forgot.
But you'll notice in this case,
um, our first ones are ensemble
two. Rather the regression
model, where we we've carved it
up pretty good, really was very
good. There was a bit of an
error here at the kind of the
top end, and so I might actually
if I were competing with this, I
might actually take the result
of this ensemble, combine it
with the gradient boosting tree
or the model that.
We saw that did really well
in the last approach to
ensemble, yet better a
better model. It looks like
our trees are still
challenged with the with
those high end with those
high end houses.
Finally, if my boosting
approach boosting looks just
a little bit different yet,
and in this particular case
I've got a problem here in
this particular case we can
do three different things.
The easiest way to apply
boosting is to actually drag a
model called gradient boosted
tree. Here with this does is it
actually applies. It looks like
what we described before where
we are taking a sample of the
data, sending it through finding
those things that.
Failed most often. Sending back
through, and so this applies all
of the boosting for us. But in a
tree it's only in a tree.
Another approach is to
actually use groups and I
should start over here
actually. So in this
particular group.
So what I've done is this. This
is how we decide whether we're
doing a boosting or bagging or
just a simple stratified
approach or what have you for
different sampling. But in this
particular case, what I've done
is I've done my start group and
I've got all my options here,
and so if I just want to do.
An index. In other words, If I
want to run this multiple times,
then uhm, I specified that I
wanted to do it twice. The
results are combined together
into the best model an we get a
result coming out the other end.
You notice end groups doesn't
have any parameters at all, it's
just required so that the group
knows where to start, what to
apply before it goes back and.
Reruns. The UM, another approach
is this one here, where what
I've actually done is I've taken
a stratified approach.
And so the stratified approach
is really interesting.
Actually, I've I've specifically
called out stratify and I'll
show you something what I've
done. Um, in the stratified
approach, I've stratified one
of the groups last week,
pointed out that
neighborhoods on the top end
or seem to be or some of the
neighborhood seemed to be
clustered toward the top end,
and so I thought I would try
um stratifying on on the
neighborhood, and so. In
other words, this is similar
to the clustering technique
where I would take.
Approach like um picking the the
particular cluster it's from in
this particular case III said
it's grouping role to
stratification So what I'm
looking for here is that each
time through this set of models
we get the best model either
regression model or decision
tree model based on the.
The neighborhood that uhm?
That was uhm, based on each
neighborhood. So In other words,
there's one pass of this
approach from start groups and
group for every single
neighborhood in the in the.
Um, in our observation inside
and then the results are
concatenated together and we get
a result. Um, I've got some
issue here. I don't know exactly
what it is, maybe I can get the
last set of results. Or maybe
not. Yeah, I got an error there
so. I had an issue with.
Hum. This here.
Should it? Maybe she we
can see results here.
No, that's not really shows
results. OK, so.
Um, see if we can do this
model comparison real quick.
Again, these are just a few
techniques that you may want to
consider for your. Improve your
to improve your modeling
results. We've seen there that
I've kind of gone from.
Something like 40,000 down
to 20,000 in this
particular case. Um, it
looks like our gradient
boosted decision tree,
where is our?
Just the without doing
any on Samling at all.
Our decision tree.
Um, the gradient boosted
version of our decision tree
bring this over here, so it's
a little easier to read.
Um?
Is a 25,000, so we've we've
significantly improved and we
can see here that the decision
tree looks really good, except
to again up to about that
350,000 range. So maybe what I
would do here is some ensemble.
A couple of gradient boosted
decision trees together, hoping
to kind of smooth out that.
That approach or that that
prediction level rather tored
the the high end. We notice the
same kind of issue.
Uh, I guess this is our decision
tree from the boosting uhm.
From our group boosting rather
and um, but we've had much
better results with our gradient
boosting tree here.
About $9000 different, so I
probably would submit both of
those models Cagle and see which
one came up better because
they're both kind of in a really
good range, so just a couple
more kind of techniques to to
consider as you.
As you focus on finishing
out your your um models
and try to get yourself a
top of the leaderboard.
All right, any questions while
I'm still in SAS?
Anybody sleeping?
Revolts.
Alright, I'm gonna go back to
PowerPoint. Quickly whips.
Oh
I'm always saying danger zone.
I know. Yes, well.
I bet you have a quick question.
No. OK. Very good.
Alright, so I hate how this
doesn't keep. Track and
we're at.
So it's likely you'll see a
question, uhm? One or two
questions on bagging and
boosting as part of the as part
of the final, but it won't be a
a significant portion. Kind of
like the other thing is always
better time on. So I want to
talk about where we're headed to
so. Um? As we talked
about a little bit early in the
semester, we've gone into a lot
of, um, um, kind of advanced
techniques in these last few few
few days and we spent a little
more time than I had anticipated
on some of the.
Um?
On our presentations, which is
great and I'm and I'm glad to
do it. So um, getting our sass
kind of stuff up and working
the switch to online has been
a challenge. So what?
Rather than introduce yet
another topic for Thursday, what
I'm going to suggest is that
Thursday will do a work. Day is
be will leave this time for you
to get together with your team
and kind of put the final
polishes on your your models an
start to pull your paper
together. Presentations for
those that have to do it and
I'll make myself available for
office hours in that day and
less. There's a significant
revolt. And you want to
cover something like
Association Market Basket
analysis on Thursday.
OK, I'm seeing quite a few
thumbs up four of you are
actually five wow, great paying
attention since this traffic
alright, perfect then uhm.
Thursday will be allowed to be a
work day and I'll make myself
available to your groups if
you'd like to chat and if
there's something you want to
do, you just can't figure out
how to do it in the software.
That would be a great time to
kind of figure it out. Tuesday
will have the last three groups
of the presentation will.
Will share the the results of
the final models from from
Chicago and. And allow the group
that that has one to wallow in
their glory and there.
Um, not having to take the
the final exam.
On Thursday, um.
I guess this is all part
of the the.
The contract is this Thursday
next Thursday are kind of Tide
together. I'll be glad to give
a work day. This week, but
next Thursday. What I'd like
to do you have completed all
of your all the work
associated with your?
With your project and UM, I I
would like to get. I would like
to have a, uh, a good rich
discussion about how we've
covered the topics this
semester. I want to do that in
class because as I told you at
the beginning of the semester,
this is a completely different
approach than than has been
taking before, and I really
appreciate the the patients
you've all had as we kind of
worked our way through it and
then we threw in the.
The curve ball of of Um Cove in
and um and working on line, and
that's been a challenge so I
just like to get, um, an
opportunity to have an open
discussion on Thursday about
about what worked well, what
didn't work well from a class
perspective, and the.
And then we will.
Um?
Then we'll spend time just kind
of recapping what?
Um?
What kinds of things you can
expect to see UM on the exam?
As I pointed out at the
beginning of class, the exam
is on a Tuesday. I don't want
you to forget from 12:45 to
2:45 PM. I'll give you more
details as it comes up. I
don't expect that the exam
will be of similar length to
what the mid term was, and so
I don't expect the exam to
take more than an hour or so,
but.
We do have this time set aside.
This is what the I got a note
from the Dean earlier this week
that just to remind students
that this is the.
Two things, number one that the
exams are to be done during the
final exam period that uhm.
And that you shouldn't have
to sit for more than two
exams in a day.
And a few other minor
reminders. So uhm, I think
that's taken care of through
the way they scheduled exams.
But like I said it the exam will
open at 12:45, the due date will
be set at 1:00 PM. But that
doesn't mean you only have 15
minutes to finish just means
that you must start between
12:45 and 1:00 PM and then
you'll have till you have two
hours to complete the example.
The time you start but you have
to start with in those first 15
minutes or so and I'll be
available online during that
time to answer questions about
the exam are too.
To provide an update or what
have you. So that's kind of our
plan. Um, we've got.
In essence, four class periods
left or the three class periods
last, sorry, one of them will be
a work day. One will be group
presentations and then will do.
The project feedback in
exam review.
In less anybody has anything
else I'm going to, um, let you.
Get on with your day so you
can focus on completing all
the other classes worth of
work that you've put off so
you could do exceptionally
well in this class.
Have a great week and if you
need help, I'll be around the
rest of the week.
Take care and good luck.